uh dishonest reporter at the Washington
Post just got a glorious well-deserved
roast thanks to the owner of Barstool
Sports Dave Portnoy catching wind of a
hit piece they were writing about him
apparently the Democracy dies in the
darkness doofuses had been reaching out
to the sponsors of a pizza event that he
hosts and asking if they felt
comfortable being associated with him
wapo didn't bother giving Portnoy a call
before hand for comment so he called
them
you're basically sending an email that
says to the effect Dave's a misogenic
racist I haven't said anything like that
if you want I can read what you actually
sent I have it we are planning to write
about the festival and how and how some
of the sponsors and participants have
drawn criticism by seemingly to
associate themselves with Dave Portnoy
who has a history of misogenic comments
and other problematic Behavior
did you said you didn't do it then I
have the exact evidence of you doing it
so I didn't say I didn't do that I said
I did that was the one that was the most
well no you that what before I before I
provided proof you said you didn't
really remember doing that and then I
read it to you and you're like oh yeah I
did it that one time so you did do it
wow she backpedaled like Lance Armstrong
in a windstorm but by the way David's
misogynistic I didn't know what you were
talking about those smear tactics seem
pretty shocking but apparently that is
how the liberal media operates
this is kind of standard journalistic
stuff like unfortunately yes
you kind of have to indicate that there
might be something negative and then you
get them to engage that's all I was
trying to do I really wanted them to
engage with me that is a sad state of
Journalism if that's a tactic that you
have to what I would say is make up
something about somebody
amen we reached out for comment from
wapo multiple times but we haven't heard
back if you want to hear more from point
Port Noy he will be on Jessie's show
tonight help him with the ratings uh so
Jesse uh um this was not about a story
it was a strategy to damage a business
by targeting and scaring advertisers we
all know how that feels I mean why is
the food editor trying to get a pizza
Festival canceled
this is uh corporate terrorism she's
supposed to be doing reviews for food
it's not like he made her samasubuko
that wasn't well presented this is a guy
who's not even a chef yeah he doesn't
even own a restaurant and this food
critic is trying to take down a
charitable event yes this is a pizza
party to help small business owners and
she's trying to destroy it so you have
Media Matters that run ad boycotts to
take down popular companies and people
and then you have journalists that run
ad boycotts to take down popular people
they're the same thing this is an agenda
so why do they have this agenda why is
Dave Portnoy such a threat that's the
question I'm going to ask him tonight
because for the Washington Post they
don't compete against Barstool stewards
is it because he's Politically Incorrect
it's because they're not in the same
tribe is it because hate sells or
division cells I don't know but this
woman and we get this all the time
you've gotten it you've gotten it this
is what they do they go in the editor
tells them what to write stories 95
written they call all your sponsors or
all your advertisers and everybody that
hates you and then they write about all
of your controversies and then five
minutes before the deadline they say hey
you'd like to read a comment exactly and
then you just check the box boom and
then it's going to kill you and it's the
most disgraceful and dishonest thing the
fact that she got caught and then lied
yes and says this is a journalistic
tactic now tell me if this is journalism
you lie to some sponsor and say
your house is on fire you got to call me
back and then they call you back and say
your house isn't actually on fire but it
might be if you don't do what we say
that's not journalism that's a threat
she's taking hostages and this is
disgraceful I'm so glad he recorded it I
wish I could record it
they're doing one on me right now and I
know it's going to go about the same way
hey it's Will Kane click here to
subscribe to the Fox News Channel on
YouTube it's the best way to get our
latest interviews and highlights and
click to subscribe to the will Kane
podcast for full episodes right now